Okay, so why don't we get started. These,
I will show you some of the small paint
contest assignments from previous years.
Is this, is this visible, is this,
I think I should pull some of the current,
maybe a
bit
about that.
So you can see that even with a smoking
program you can be can make incredible,
incredible scenes.
So this is the thanks.
So this is the state of the art lecture.
Basically what we are interested in this
and the next lecture is starting from
the very first algorithm that was ever
created to solve the rendering equation,
the classical path tracer up to
the most sophisticated works,
some of them which came
out less than a week ago.
And I won't go into deep mathematical
details for most of these techniques.
What I would like you to know is the
basic idea and the intuition behind the
method and why we are
doing the things we do.
So deep mathematical details will also
be there in the form of links where you
can look behind the curtain and you will
see what is exactly going on in there.
Now before we start with
the state of the art park,
there's a few things that we need
to discuss. One, this person.
So we have talked about
indices of refraction,
the index of refraction for
different materials. What was it?
It was a number.
So in every code,
in every program, in every
theory, we use numbers. Well,
in reality in this is of
refractions are not numbers.
They are in fact functions.
What does it mean?
They could be functions that depend
on the wavelength of incoming light.
And what it exactly means is that there
are materials that refract incoming
light of different colors
to different directions.
And that's quite profound because
you will see the beautiful effects
of diff dispersion and second,
and there are also some supplementary
videos that you should take a look at all.
This is a good example of it.
This is a prison.
So you can see that the incoming light
is white and the prison does break down
to this white incoming light to
all possible parlors. There are
another good example of this is rainbows.
So whenever you are on a family trip and
they are asking what you're looking at
and if you accidentally
don't say rainbow you will,
you will maybe say this person and
they will put you in an asylum instead.
So, but don't worry, you
are correct scientifically
and that's all that matters.
You can also see and maybe
not so beneficial and not
so beautiful effect of this
person.
It is called chromatic aberration.
This means that we have a camera lens
that is possibly not the highest quality
and it can introduce artifacts like this
because different colors of light are
reflected into different directions and
you don't get the sharp initial that you
would be looking for.
Wow.
This is a dispersion
rendered inside lux renders.
So you can see that with
physically based rendering,
you can actually capture this effect
and you can also render timelines.
So if y'all have a fiance and you would
like to buy a rink but you're broke
because her university student,
then you can just render one.
Then you can also render
one with this person.
But see if you have a nerd girlfriend.
Because if salt and maybe she will be
happy about it and most people aren't and
I speak from experience
and you can also see this really
beautiful effect in the old old pink Floyd
album cover called the
dark side of the moon.
There are also some videos about this in
the internet rendered with Lux render.
Take a look. No. The first question is,
is the index of refraction
of glass constant?
Well let's look it up.
Obviously we may have glasses that are
made and manufactured in different ways.
There are,
most of them are not completely clear.
They are some kind of
some kinds of a mixture.
So there are different kinds of class.
But let's just pick one randomly from
a database that gives you in this of
refraction and you can see
that it is actually not flat.
It is not a constant there. There's
something happening in the function.
So this means that there are glass tops
that have dispersion effects and even
only slightly because you can see that
we have between the minimum and the
maximum, there is not such a large
difference, but there is something.
So you could say that at least this
kind of glass introduces some degree of
dispersion.
So let's take a look.
What do you think about this
image that's this caustic,
have any kind of dispersion effect
or does it not? What do you think?
Is it a bit more colorful around
the edges or is it completely wild?
Exactly.
Did you read
okay, could good bit gift.
Give me one more opinion.
What do you think
it's
okay.
Uh, it might be a rainbow but it may be
significantly smaller so maybe you would
have to zoom in really close to seed
or angel. So this is up for debate.
We could see that the IOR seems to be non
constant and therefore there should be
a dispersion effect.
Some artists claim that they can spot
the difference between a physical based
render.
Even for materials like that and simple
RGB rendering where you cannot render
these dispersion affects correctly. This
is up for debate whether you can see it,
but science says that yes there is.
Even if there is a slight difference,
there is a difference.
It feel right to more know
more about this person.
There is this wonderful series
called cosmos, a spacetime Odyssey.
Have any of you heard of this before?
Raise your hand.
Okay. If you are, feel
so. This is, this is,
this is hosted by the
magnificent Neil degrasse Tyson.
Yeah,
Neil degrasse Tyson and you
should absolutely watch it.
So everyone who hasn't watched it yet,
I'd like to hear your excuse or at least
I like to hear that you will go home
and watch it.
So this,
this episode is about that this Persian
mostly and we will know all about this
person if you want.
Okay.
Now we have another question because
we have written an RGB render.
So we if if you look up the source
code of small paint everywhere,
you just see RGB, RGB, RGB.
How do we write a correct
physically based render?
And even before that,
how do we even represent
light in the visible spectrum?
Not a good answer to this is to introduce
a function that describes how much
light is carried at different wavelengths.
Now this will be a continuous function
that we could call spectral power
distribution.
And you can see that at
these lower wavelength,
there is not too much light carried on
the higher wavelength there. There's more.
So you can put this
representation into your render,
and what you would do is that
you would just a knife solution,
you would pick a randomly
chosen wavelength and you
would trace way into the
scene using this way of life.
And if you do this,
you can actually do another kind of Monte
Carlo integration because you also add
one more dimension of integration.
And this one more dimension
would be overweight lens
because you would also be,
still has stickily taking random samples
of the rendering equation for a given
wave flags in a given collar.
And then you would need to sum it up
somehow to get a sensible solution.
There's more about this
in PBR t chapter five.
Okay.